[Musique]
l'essentiel à retenir
nous sommes à la 33ème session donc ça
veut dire que la commission de sinceny
avis dans le temps pour les populations
aujourd'hui c'est un projet on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure signature d'une
convention entre l'union européenne et
la commission de l'océan indien pour
justement protéger un la pêche et ne pas
laisser l'ensemble de nos océans autour
de 200 indiens autour de nous il dans
l'océan indien être pillés donc ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya une prise de
conscience de nous deux nous dirigeons
pour nos populations et relayé par
l'union européen c'est une institution
qui aujourd'hui à l'ensemble de la force
d'abord six membres sur les 6 un projet
comment partager et tout se fait à
l'unanimité
vous avez vu à l'intérieur de ces
réunions et en même temps aujourd'hui
une base financière ait une base
juridique ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
mme et ben nous avons devant nous à
chaque jour sa sa force sa recherche de
résultats pour les populations mais en
même temps tous se fera avec la
constance de l'union à l'intérieur pour
nos populations de ninjas ou ciani
[Musique]